have you been looking for feedback on
your youtube channel would you like
someone who does youtube full time to
just take a look at all the pieces of
your channel and give you feedback well
i'm excited because on today's episode
of the youtube made simple show i am
joined by my special guest rob from vid
iq and we're gonna spend the next hour
reviewing your channels and giving you
all the feedback to help you succeed on
youtube this year
[Music]
welcome back to the youtube made simple
show my name is heather torres i'm your
host of this show here on the think
media podcast make sure you're
subscribed if you're not already
subscribed here on this channel we do
have our main channel which focuses on
the tips and tools to help you grow your
youtube channel but here on the podcast
we love to go deeper into youtube
tactics and more about the content
creator themselves we've got episodes
all about how to handle unsupportive
spouses how to get your productivity up
as a content creator and even how to
make your first six to seven figures
here on youtube so make sure you're
subscribed here on the channel now i'm
excited because we are jumping into live
channel reviews today and i'm joined by
none other than one of my favorite
co-hosts from the vid iq team rob
welcome to the show rob how you doing
hey heather thank you for having me on
once again i'm so delighted that you
still consider me a special guest not
just a average run-of-the-mill regular
guest and hello to all of you think
media rights i do just want to say a
special shout out to the creepypasta
go girls farmer king george i was in the
chat for 20 minutes beforehand just um
having a casual conversation as well as
axel as well so just hello to all of you
for conversing and
it's a special week for most of us
creators heather in that typically we
would be at vidcon
but for travel purpose travel
restrictions i'm unable to travel right
now it's like good news bad news i've
just become a canadian citizen but i
don't have a passport so i can't travel
but i've got that you know audit itch
so
you inviting me on here is going to
satisfy
my need to audit here there and
everywhere looking forward to it i love
it yes sean is actually at the vidiq
booth today doing channel audits so
we're auditing everyone everywhere today
um i am also i'm feeling a little fomo
because i'm not at uh you know i'm not
there but at the same time we get to be
here right rob in our in our studios at
home and um while i think it's fun to
hang out with a bunch of people in real
life i actually love the virtual crowd
that we get um like box expression we've
got flip spine fun daryl is here so i'm
excited for our virtual fam that gets to
join us live well um let's get into a
couple of channel reviews rob if you
want to grab the first one um here's how
we're gonna do channel reviews so if you
would like your channel reviewed today
and you are on youtube all you need to
do is raise your hand by giving us the
raised hand emoji or just saying yes
please review my channel our team is in
the back and they will actually grab
your channel for us we're going to do
these in no particular order rob and i
are just going to be bringing the most
value we can um to uh to you based on
the experiences that we have had by
coaching hundreds of entrepreneurs and
content creators and what is working on
youtube right now um if you're joining
us live on facebook or from one of our
groups we want to welcome you here as
well you can drop it over on facebook
and our team will grab that there but
i'm seeing raised hands like crazy and
uh and again there's no way to really
get in the front of the line here it's
just gonna be all random selection to
get you the best channel reviews
possible we'll spend a few minutes on
each review and vidiq has some amazing
tools that we're going to be sharing
with you here inside of this live so if
you
have your vin iq tool ready to go uh if
you don't you can download it right now
by going to vidiq.com forward slash
think and when you open up your vid iq
there's so many incredible tools we're
going to be showing you some of those
today during this channel review period
but rob what is the first channel you
have if you want to share your screen i
will pull it up for you and we'll get
that ready
good point i completely forgot to do
that there we are i'm sharing my screen
now and we want to say hello
to christy davis first of all
congratulations already on the
phenomenal success your channel has uh
had so far 110 000 subscribers i hope
that silver play button has arrived or
is very imminent
from the channel banner and from the
thumbnails in general i'm getting a very
strong vibe about what your value
proposition is in that you're going to
help people
uh with a certain diet be keto low carb
type one uh diabetic so
already i know if i'm in the right place
or the wrong place as a viewer that's
fantastic to see
if i was to critique your thumbnails and
this is going to be a very general
observation because what i do appreciate
is that in certain niches there is a
certain style of thumbnail for example
in the shopping hall
genre the thumbnails can be quite
chaotic and busy and i'm getting a
similar vibe from the thumbnails here
which may be good for the general
audience but i'm wondering if there's an
opportunity here to
test new things when i look at all of
the thumbnails
i can't see a certain focus on a
particular food that you could maybe
promote in particular and then tell me
you know how low the carbs are on the
aura very interesting vital piece of um
nutritional information to focus on one
particular thing that's where i may be
experimenting with in terms of the
thumbnails and i see that like the the
views to subscribe ratio is you know
around about five to ten percent so it
looks as if you may be getting a lot of
search traffic people maybe subscribe
for one or two videos but then you're
not sustaining their interest that could
be that is a challenge for channels such
as you and
we do sometimes go to the lowest uh for
uh denominator here sort by most popular
i've seen that you have various videos
from a few years ago
that were very successful and to borrow
a think media phrase
success leaves clues did i get that
right heather have i remembered it yeah
there we go you did
maybe it's worth revisiting some of
these videos like you went to aldi and
you had a neck
carb bread keto friendly could you do
that again have they got any new
products in that particular area or
could you go to lidl uh you've been to
little as well like because i think this
may be a uk uh shopping channel as well
uh so
it's is it an opportunity to go to asda
go to waitrose go to all of the
different uk shopping brands i'm trying
to remember because i haven't lived
there for many years but you know can
you visit all of these shops and do
versus and compare videos perhaps you
already have but in on the first
impressions those are some of the things
i may be looking at for your channel
chrissy but congratulations on the
success so far
woohoo really awesome i love being able
to see channels that are just starting
to rise that are really starting to take
the things that we say and putting them
into practice it's always good to see
those all right my first review is gonna
come from lego head production a z
and um i am a huge lego fan i don't know
about you rob are you a lego fan huge
i've already filled up my apartment with
lego and we're buying a new house so
that i can buy new lego stuff my pride
and joy is the avengers helicarrier
three and a half thousand pieces took me
three weeks to build love it
now i want to build something else yeah
we uh i have two kiddos two oh i have
three kiddos but two that are still very
much into legos our entire section of
the garage is from you know ceiling to
floor lego bins i i always tell my uh my
friends that i should own stock and lego
at this point with all the legos that
grandparents um seem to give them but
let's go ahead and look at a few things
that you're doing now what i'm seeing
here first rob is that lego heads is
going straight into short form video and
you're doing short form video but
um i am seeing when i'm even seeing like
you're titling for these um i want you
to work on your titling because right
now i'm not being grabbed by the title
like this one uh here here we go here's
an example if if you hate your roommate
hashtag short that's a good title and
it's 1.6 k views in four days but if you
go over a little bit more okay this is a
more longer form video so i messed that
one up but right here you'll never
believe this figure is rare
i think it's good um but i would i would
maybe blur out the figure so you don't
even know what the figure is so title
thumbnail um objective there and i am tr
i was watching this video so i wanted to
see
so what he's doing too okay sorry i'm
gonna lower the
volume here come on volume there we go
um what i'm noticing that that's not
really good let me move back here what
i'm noticing that you're doing is you're
not actually showing your head so this
is what i would call a face less channel
and i'm gonna pull this back up because
now my internet's deciding not to do the
channel wouldn't that be great right on
the daily screen
always works uh on these days okay so
you're not showing your face so it is
kind of like a faceless channel um let
me go up here to the top part and i like
to recommend this here you don't
actually so this is my second channel um
you can just put the name of that or you
can say to watch more go here but i
would keep people on this channel i
wouldn't actually send them to your next
channel um i would keep them here and i
would use this place right up top this
is for all creators you should use this
place up top to send someone to go
deeper with you so it does not need to
be subscribing if you are a content
creator who um sells courses or you sell
merch or you sell um uh coaching or
you're a real estate agent you want them
to go here uh with this you don't
necessarily want them to just subscribe
on your channel
um also this is great for an avatar too
i'm just seeing this just lego head
because you are faceless so that makes
sense and when i'm scrolling through
what are your most popular videos that's
what i like to check next so most
popular videos um looks like your shorts
are working so i think you're doing a
really good job i also want to
compliment you on your thumbnails uh rob
you talk about this a lot and having
that contrasting color and i even like
here how he made the outline of the
actual lego that is on gray that is gray
have green around it so um i think you
are doing great i would probably tap
into
what is popular with lego right now so
there's a couple different types of
videos that you could be creating and i
would really recommend that you do trend
surfing when it comes to the lego space
so what is like the hot new lego set out
right now what could you be doing
that uh that people are already
searching what's the trend happening in
your space that you could go deeper on
so that would be my review for you so
far and i want to compliment you too on
your uploads uh five uploads in the last
30 days so congratulations and this is a
cool um
this is a cool way to see some stats rob
uh by vidiq you hit stats and you can
actually see this creator is growing by
8 000 views in the last 30 days 33
subscribers and 5 video uploads
you are what we call my friend going for
green and you are winning so great job
for going for green on all of your stats
that are available there i do want to
let you know that if you've already
raised your hand for a channel review
you do not need to repost it over and
over and over our team is grabbing those
um in no particular order we'll be doing
those but if you've already raised your
hand for a review no need to keep
raising your hand i saw some people just
back-to-back back-to-back and uh we want
to keep the chat clean and ready to go
if you have a question about channel
reviews as well you can ask that in the
chat and we can get to some questions
but rob who do you have next
just to add there um heather you said
going for green that must mean they are
a sustainable creator yes how'd you like
that i just wanted to add as well to the
lego channel that we were looking at i
quickly um just fed
the simple phrase lego figures into our
ai title generator because this is
something that can just take a keyword
and make some really intriguing curious
titles and so you know any um creator
who has vid iq boost
is able to take advantage of this and
we've got some interesting suggestions
for lego like lego what's the best lego
figure eight essential lego figures you
must have lego figures a comparison of
the best-selling sets and if you're not
happy with any of these you just simply
click refresh and then you can have
another bunch of suggestions and
you can tailor it a little bit you could
put in star wars lego figures and it
will always
essentially churn out some really
interesting intriguing titles because
that's one of the things you were
looking at heather so that's just a
little plug for one of our
new tools that we're really excited
about here at vid iq but now we're going
to look at
through a darkly glass this channel has
300 subscribers and what i was noticing
uh from this channel is that credit to
their commitment to consistency they are
publishing i would say two or three
videos a week several videos a week and
when i look at just you know the
consistency on brand content like that
the thumbnails are very consistent it
looks like they're staying on topic
consistently and i think that's been
rewarded in their view counts heavy
because if you look to like two or three
months ago they were getting 40 views
100 views 200 views if i go to the most
recent views they're starting to get
300 views as a minimum 600 views 500
views and so this is clear evidence
that you have established your target
audience and you are continuing to feed
that target audience with every single
video that you make so that when youtube
puts your latest thumbnail on the home
page
people instinctively say oh yeah i've
already watched this creator i like what
they make i'm going to click on this
next video and watch what's coming up
now with that being said
again there are a few
thumbnail tweaks i would suggest
personally i wouldn't be including the
season number and episode number in
there because a brand new viewer could
see season one episode 73 and think
blimey that's a lot of episodes i need
to catch on catch up on before i can
watch this creator's latest video
and i would take the text in the bottom
right hand corner which is covered up a
little bit sometimes by the time stamp
and place it in the top left-hand corner
where you currently have the season
number and episode number because i just
don't think it's needed necessarily for
the video pitch same in the title as
well i would flip it i would have the
important aspects in terms of
who you're talking about whether it be
sean mcfade to david morehouse uh or or
any of ever stephen lawson i would put
that front and center and i would be
putting the episode number at the very
end of a title or perhaps not even
including it in the title i think that's
something that you can talk about very
early on when somebody clicks on a video
what season number you are what episode
number you are because you don't want to
create barriers to entry for that new
viewer you just want to get the
pitch for that video
to really see it into the viewer's mind
in two seconds to get them to click and
then worry about the the progression of
the series that you're on once
somebody's watching
wow
really really great rob thank you so
much for that one i am excited because i
have a channel that has just started and
i'd love to maybe bring up rob uh let's
do some titling for this one because i
see that he's already starting to ride
this trend but there may be a way that
we could give him some title ideas and
this channel is the finance with eric
channel and what i like about what eric
is doing he just got started on youtube
and what i like about what he's doing is
uh well one he actually is doing um
faceless art chat what is this called
art channel they're not art channels
it's a doodle channel is that what it's
called where he's doing a voiceover and
uh he has the graphics coming up to
explain um those pieces of his uh to
explain the video which i think is a
really cool um
which is a really cool way to make
videos on youtube but if we can look up
maybe inflation rob because that is a
huge talking point at this moment and i
see that he's already starting with
inflation and recession simply explained
um i would actually think that this is
going to be a writing trend in the next
uh few months and so what are some ideas
rob that we have from the vid iq tool of
what types of videos he could be
creating so there's two ways to look at
this from a video q perspective you can
just look at the keyword itself and i've
typed in inflation
uh the numbers for this are good
ironically in that the search volume is
high
and there's not as much competition as
there might be so currently
demand outweigh supply which means that
you as a creator should probably get in
there with your own education on the
subject
here's a tool that we've recently
introduced which i think is awesome
especially for search based channels it
will take a key word and turn it into
questions down in this bottom right hand
corner so i put in inflation and it's
giving me
300 potential questions and the one that
really intrigues me here heather look at
this one how to profit from inflation
that is a really intriguing title
uh for a creator to try and work with in
terms of saying that you know for 99 of
people inflation is a bad thing but for
those who understand it and leverage it
the best you know just like creators
understanding new tools that could be
something that could be really
profitable if you watch this video and
then yeah there's another 300
suggestions here so you could you can
generate like uh enough ideas here to
keep you occupied uh for the next year
on inflation going back to the titles i
didn't just throw in our title generator
inflation what's a big deal what is
inflation seven ways to combat inflation
and real estate you're not happy with
any of them just refresh it and you've
got to bundle more suggestions inflation
in different countries inflation
increases i like this one what's your
next move should you put all of your
money out of cryptocurrency and put it
in gold or silver or again i have no
idea about financial advice this is not
legal advice of course but you should
probably invest all of your money right
now under your mattress
uh that's what i'm gonna suggest
that's what i'm doing too rob i'm doing
that exact same amazing financial plan
um and i love that i like um these are
these helmets and things because they've
probably actually increased in value
like um marvel superhero toys and stuff
toys that's what you should invest in
right now
tangible toys yeah that's what we're
gonna suggest this is not financial
advice we are youtube auditors
um but i just want to also say
congratulations i see you've been
creating a content your your first video
was mathematic analysis three months ago
but i can tell you actually decided to
go all in
on the finance niche and rob he's
already at 1 000 subscribers so you are
on your way uh with your views to be
able to uh oh thank you thank you yeah
here we come hopefully
i like that you are on your way to being
able to get monetized on youtube and i
can let you know that this is a great
space to be in if you want to be
monetized on youtube now some other uh
types of videos you could be creating i
loved how rob gave you those pieces of
advice
versus videos um you could be reviewing
apps or um or uh different places that
people different software that people
could be using um to be a good investor
a wise investor there's a lot of
different types of videos you can do and
i just want to say congrats on getting
over
four videos which is one video per week
that's what we recommend here one video
per week happening on your channel so
you've got the consistency down and
you're starting to make videos in the
right niche so great job on that who do
you have next rob
i am looking at sketches and scrubs they
are at 2
300 subscribers
and just instinctively again looking at
the channel banner looking at the
thumbnails if i'm into art and into i
guess watercolors or similar i already
know i'm in the right place and that's a
fantastic place to be in for a creator
i'm not having to figure out what this
channel's about exactly
if i'm part of a target audience i'm
going to be starting to hunt around
which videos are a particular interest
and again just from
first impressions the numbers look good
to me as well heather in that the
channel has 2 000 subscribers and some
of these videos are getting close to the
number of subscribers uh or just a
little under 2 000 views a thousand
views 850 views a very strong stuff
thumbnails again i think are of a
particular strength here in that
usually what i would recommend to most
uh creators is a few dominant colors on
their thumbnails but i think in this art
area in particular when you have a
collection of colors and almost that
organized chaos type of vibe where you
can see many different colors but it's
still
clear what the thumbnail is trying to
illustrate i like that style as well and
i'm actually at the point here
everywhere i'm looking at i'm thinking
what do i really recommend here because
the channel is is growing
efficiently uh they've got good numbers
in this case it's like continue doing
what you're doing obviously the
the general advice go to your most
popular see what you can improve there
um
yeah because everything's so consistent
however i'm struggling to say to pick
out like anything that they're doing
wrong necessarily
that's my favorite though that means
that they are that she's being
consistent she's making good content i
would say in a case like this it's do
more of what's already working great job
on on what you have going and here's
maybe one of the tips when you've got
consistency down when you've got the
niche that you're in down when you're
already making great content now i want
you to work on your business so i want
you to be thinking about the revenue
streams i don't know rob if she has a
website ready to go how can people
contact you how can people purchase from
you
that would be the next piece that i
would say because you want to be having
multiple streams of income happening on
your channel this is a marketing arm of
the pieces that you can actually be
creating when it comes to financing this
as well so um great job i think this is
a this is a well-exampled channel of
someone who's really um understanding
how youtube works descriptions are
well stacked with links to other pieces
of content uh it looks like they've got
affiliate links and also that's a really
cool
emoji i want to start using that this
little like spinny thing i've never seen
that before
um
i guess the one thing i may suggest or
you may want to experiment with here and
possibly not on this channel you know
test it on a second channel to begin
with is shorts because your videos are
quite long yes looks like they're often
live streams or at least 20 minutes i'm
wondering if you can experiment with
time lapsing these into almost like
visually satisfying uh drawings using
some popular music
that might be something to experiment
with but i always suggest if you've
never done short form content and you
don't want to disrupt the flow of your
channel and your audience's expectations
just try on a uh on a experimental
shorts channel to begin with really
really smart and uh yes uh she is
launching kofi in a week so that's um
that's great to be able to
uh have a revenue stream for your
youtube channel all right well this
question came in from christian
rocker question best way to monetize and
build a brand from a reaction channel
what advice do you have rob and i'll
attack on mine after yours i'm glad you
asked me first because you've probably
got a ton of really good answers and you
would have stolen one of mine i think
it's tapping in to the rituals of your
tribe and what i mean by that is if you
have like funny catchphrases or like you
have funny facial expressions you can
maybe print that onto onto t-shirts and
turn it into merch that type of thing
and i think perhaps the other thing you
might be looking to do is tie into
potential brand sponsorship deals for
example if you're reacting to the latest
star wars obi-wan kenobi um
franchise series by the way what did you
think of that in the chat uh i kind of
give it a six out of ten i thought it
was all right could have been a little
bit better but i enjoyed it anyway i'm
i'm waffling at this point but what i
was going to say is uh if you're
reacting to a certain television series
then try and think of branded
sponsorship deals that relate to whether
it be you know lego star wars could have
been a perfect example of this or if
it's strange of things
i don't know maybe you can promote the
um
dungeons and dragons has been a very
popular part of that so those would be
my thoughts what about you heather
yeah uh you are hitting the nail on the
head there rob i would say wow that was
i felt like a dj at that point you know
like radio djs where they say that
um yeah you at this point if your
reaction channel that is entertainment
and so entertainment channels really
grow and create brands by one getting
massive views so writing trends because
you can be paid to be a content creator
on youtube branding it out like rob said
i would even say creating some type of
paid membership um like rob said because
that helps you to go deeper so one of
our examples is we have um we have a
reaction channel that he reacts to music
and uh and leonardo torres actually
created several streams of income so
he's got brand deals coming in he's
getting paid by youtube he has super
chats where he goes live and he'll make
a few hundred dollars in a day just from
super chats because people are
interested in the content that he has
and he has different ways for people to
be involved so i would say um it's not
just about being a reaction channel it's
about creating experiences so how can
you create experiences and build a tribe
around you that's interested in what
you're doing and i've seen very
successful reaction channels um happen
because they understand that it's about
the community it's not about them it's
about the community so how can you be
creating epic experiences um to that
movie review channels so uh we have a uh
someone in our community that does movie
review channels and inside of his
membership group they had an entire
discussion rob actually on the star wars
because he he always giving his advice
and they were having back and forth
conversation inside of that paid
community so there's a lot of different
ways you can go deeper um with uh with
the reaction style channels and i think
um it's it's one of the best ways to
grow on youtube because you are writing
trends a reaction channel is writing
trends and so that helps you to get in
the algorithm more helps
your brand grow and i think it's a great
way to get started
all right who do we have next rob
we are looking at banksy the eye racer
and again channel banner first
impressions
i think this is a
gaming racing channel it can sometimes
be a little deceptive no way that looks
so real to me rob exactly when you look
at these videos you think
this is real right and sometimes it is
sometimes it isn't um but just from
mousing over i'm seeing that there's a
person probably uh in their gaming setup
um ready to do some uh online game
wrestling i believe thumbnails a game
for a channel of a relatively small size
are pretty fantastic you know they
really pop out of the screen
some of these are a little repetitive
but that might be because they are live
streams and this is a tricky thing i
don't know if it is for you have it
because
we do like a weekly live screen live
stream which is channel audits um we've
been using the same thumbnail for about
18 months and i decided that maybe i
need to create a collection of four or
five different thumbnails because even
if i don't know what's gonna happen in
the live streams you can channel audits
can go in
any which way shape or form um i felt as
if i needed like a one with like a dark
mode thumbnail a light mode thumbnail
maybe the icons a little bit differently
and as soon as i change the thumbnails
from week to week we've seen an increase
of 20
in our audience
because i think it's a case of
their
they're familiar with our branding but
it's a different thumbnail so maybe it's
something they haven't seen before or a
new live stream so
even though and what i'm highlighting
here is that all of these thumbnails i
think as far as i'm aware are exactly
the same
and these are coming up pretty regularly
so perhaps creating a
catalog of different thumbnails for a
live stream might be of a suggestion and
then the other thing i wanted to ask
here is how popular is this game i think
it's iracing as far as i'm aware
i'm curious to know what the
the audience size is for this and just
doing a search on youtube to try and
find out
how many views other channels are
getting
it's good that there's
i would say a high recycling of content
because if you go to the search bar and
you've seen the videos at the top of the
search rankings are like 10 years old
then maybe there's not that much
interest anymore but you know visa being
made relatively
recently
but the view counts aren't necessarily
that high i mean we've got this channel
here iracing how big are they they've
got 200 000 subscribers and their recent
videos are getting
you know 7 000 subscribers 25 000
subscribers is very limited audience
for this topic and that might mean that
there's a ceiling for this channel
and how and especially for smaller
channels because
what tends to happen is when there's a
relatively small audience for a topic
then a few channels tend to dominate it
and it's hard for anybody else to muscle
in so that is maybe something to
consider i'm not saying that they should
stop playing this game
but are there crossover games like is
there any similarities here between this
and something a lot more popular such as
forza 5 for example and that's where you
can maybe do versus videos so you're not
just going to a completely different
game you're comparing one game to
another and then just final point
all of these videos
are relatively long
have this has this creator experimented
with shorter videos maybe five minutes
or less this might be the best clips
from your live stream or something
that's a little more educational how to
because it could be
that for this
audience
the commitment of one hour 40 minutes
for a live stream or 20 minutes for a
video on demand is perhaps too much
and if you haven't experimented with
shorter form content then maybe that is
something to take a look at
whoa what a review rob i love that
people were excited about that one
inside of the uh chat and the chat is on
fire so um you can keep raising your
hand if you'd like to uh get a channel
review and i will have a next channel
that comes up but this is a great
question um from short for matt um how
would you build a gaming channel focused
on live streaming and game play
walkthroughs i know you're more of an
expert of the gaming side than i am rob
so what is your advice for him there and
i'm thinking i wish dan was here today
and just bring dan in and he he would
help out okay so
there is a word
there that uh that scares me whenever i
see it and that is walk through
so i want to caution here because we
audit so many channels that do
walk through gaming and what we see is
that
they make like 200 videos over the
course of a year
and they're still getting less than 10
views
per video
and it's might not necessarily because
their content is is bad or
uh they're not focused enough
this area
is so competitive and has been done for
so long on youtube and so just
unfortunately through you know we're
talking about supply and demand earlier
on you're at such a disadvantage already
because there are so many
walk through channels already and
my advice but this is just my general
advice
is that i would be focusing not
necessarily on the walkthrough
uh element of it but of the educational
element of how to get better at this
game how to get more experience what are
the secrets that you would want to find
that's how i would possibly be thinking
about pitching it to an audience instead
of saying in the title something along
the lines of uh elden ring walk through
episode 49
because just unfortunately
there's so many people have already done
that and there's such large creators
doing that and you have to try and find
your
usp in in that place and that can be a
really difficult thing to do and so just
when i see the word walkthrough
it does send shivers through my spine
just because we've ordered so many
channels that get stuck in that space
and they keep throwing stuff against the
wall expecting something different to
happen and it doesn't so unless you
already have
some proof of concepts that your
audience is building through
walkthroughs i would try and approach
this area a little bit differently
yes good advice rob uh i'll leave it at
that because i think that you
you definitely uh picked up on the one
thing i was gonna say as well which was
walkthroughs um i want to bring up the
next question and then we'll do a couple
more channel reviews but uh this one i
thought was really good this is from
pots and pans really great name by the
way because i know exactly what you do
right cooking what are some of the best
thumbnails for a cooking channel and my
advice for anyone who really wants to
figure out how to make great thumbnails
especially around food or around
products is i want you to study other
channels if there's one thing that you
can see it's what is
already actually working so i typed into
my uh youtube search bar best summer
salad because i wanted to see what would
come up and i found this channel
honeysuckle now honeysuckle is uh 1.2
million subscribers right now and it
looks like she's been actually on uh
youtube for uh uh a while she's almost
at uh a hundred million just shy
of 100 million i mean come on
honeysuckle and she's got a cookbook and
so i want you to be studying the greats
i'm going to be studying what's already
working um on youtube and here's a
couple things that i can see one it's
light and fresh like i want these
cheesecake this this looks amazing is
that what says cheesecakes okay what are
this looks amazing five breakfasts i
want these i cannot make this but i want
this um some of the things i'm seeing
too is she is actually putting herself
in the photo and i think that's because
she's definitely built brand uh over
time because look at her previous photos
did not have her in them so when you
look at her previous thumbnails
it's all light and airy and i think
that's a big thing around food
photography i want to uh encourage you
to actually look up on youtube how to do
food photography because you should be
using different ways to be diffusing
light onto the subject which would be
the food to make beautiful photography
now on a different side this is cowboy
kent he's one of our students inside of
video ranking academy and you'll notice
here that his thumbnails it's all about
the meat it's all about the barbecue
it's all about uh you know it's all
about the stews and you'll notice that
it's kind of the same thumbnail over and
over and over just a different kent and
the food so you need to figure out what
style is best for you but i'm gonna
recommend that you take maybe take a
course on how to do food photography
because your title and your thumbnail
matter so much to get someone to click
through to actually watch the video so
you want to make sure you're actually
getting great uh thumbnails designed so
that you can do that all right well hey
this video is brought to you by
vid iq i've got none other than rob from
vidiq here so if you're just joining us
welcome to our live stream where we go
live and review your channels here uh
giving you tips and tools and our tool
of the week is vid iq it is one of the
tools that we use every single day here
at think media and you can get your
first 30 days at vidiq.com forward slash
think rob you've already showed us one
of the cool tools uh when it comes to
vid iq but i just love seeing all of the
different features that are available on
youtube when you have vid iq installed
you want to show us just a few of those
um
different tools rob yeah let's do a
quick whistle stop tour through some of
our stuff then i mean the most favorite
tool
i always say and it's one of the free
tools is your channel checkup real-time
stats bar so no matter where you are on
youtube i can just quickly mouse over
and find out that our channel is getting
three and a half thousand views per hour
we're up
uh 13 on views over the last seven days
i just love being able to check in on
that without having to go to the youtube
studio but a more research based
perspective um what we have here is a
tool called views per hour and it can
tell us how many views a video is
getting
even if it's been published
years
years before for example we have this
video here from an acapella group
singing the uefa europa league theme
tune i believe and even though it's a
year old it's still getting a 116 views
per hour and when you're researching
channels in your own space i mean i will
confess you know i'm not gonna lie i
sometimes go to think media's channel
and i have a little bit of spy on their
channel and i find out what videos are
performing well for them right now and
it was showing me that some of videos
like are getting you know 22 views per
hour 26 views per hour 23 views per hour
so that looks to be the average but
there were some videos that are probably
getting lots more views per hour if i
can maybe find one on the screen
however anywhere still getting lots of
views per hour on the channel heather oh
all of our all of our videos rob all of
our videos are
so i so well what you can do is you can
click on the trending screen and then
that's going to shuffle all the videos
around and then say all right so
think media has this
weird thing that they
put out these sound effects and they get
tons and tons of views from it like
these ones from five months ago still
gets 200 views per hour i'm starting to
think heather that you the the think
media empire should have like a little
side business where you're just doing um
rosy free sound effects maybe have your
own channel doing that because man man
you are pulling in the views there which
is which is pretty spectacular so that's
another form of research if i wanted to
be even sneakier
what i could do is use the add
competitor tool up here and then this is
going to add it to the list of other
competitors that i'm following including
brian g johnson colin and samia film
move etc etc and we can see how our
videos and other videos are performing
together and if there are any breakout
topics in our competitive space that
tells us that maybe we need to make a
video on that topic as well so that's
just like i was just randomly scrolling
through some of our tools i've already
picked out four there but it's literally
just the tip of the iceberg of what we
offer here at vid iq with the fantastic
offers that you have um as our affiliate
header
well i hope everyone gets their uh vid
iq installed let us know actually in the
chat do you already have vid iq is it
already installed because there's so
many great features on there um that you
could get if you're raising your hand
right now um you only need to raise your
hand one time our team is grabbing all
the channels we are randomly selecting
them we're gonna head into the second
half of our channel reviews and i'm
excited rob because i want to do a
little bit of keyword and title research
for the cello online because i love when
we get to pull up unique and interesting
channels this is a cello teacher and uh
and i love that he already has clay
already has different uh
programs that he's offering so he's
making money he's doing uh video
exchange lessons so you can get lessons
online from the from this cello teacher
and he's breaking into the shorts his
cello bow tape actually just got 3.4
000 subscribers over the last eight days
so let's give some channel ideas to the
cello online what do you have rob
okay just doing a quick search here
again in our keyword research uh related
keywords and we've got cover music
apparently uh love songs of cello covers
is something that's quite uh popular as
well
questions i'm always looking at
questions here how to make a cello tape
how to train your dragon cello i guess
maybe somebody's done a popular cover
version of that so lots of suggestions
here
and i'm going to be honest i don't know
what's going to come up here i'm just
going to put in cello for our title
recommendation
it may not have enough of a keyword here
but i'm i'm going to try it we're going
to risk it we're going to see what comes
up with cello
and
okay not bad actually some good
tutorials here oh i mean for me who's a
complete layman what's the difference
between a violin and a cello yeah there
we go that that's a one worth
potentially making and then just refresh
again
there you go that could be an
interesting vlog one uh why am i a cello
player
you tell a little bit more of your story
and you know as a motivational i know um
on think media uh sean did a video very
recently um it was really motivational
uh heather and you know that could be in
a similar vein to
to why become why anybody should become
a cello player so again quite a bit of
research there um only took me 30
seconds and i've already got some ideas
brewing if i knew how to play a cello
really good rob and i hope that gives
you some uh different uh titles that you
could go with and i'm seeing here that
he is trying to dominate the shorts game
so he's going all in on shorts for his
cello
uh
um channel and when i'm looking through
just kind of some of the shorts well
let's see because success leaves clues
so what can you make part twos of um why
celloists don't do this that's a smart
one so that you could even make a part
two of that is there a difference
between oh that's good so difference
between the um amount of the cellos
that's really smart and it looks like
you're going into um i'm definitely out
of my depths of knowledge in this space
but i would think that this is probably
uh a song or a person who uh what is it
called composed a song there so i would
say that success will leave clues and i
was also just looking just on
youtube i just typed in cello because i
wanted to see what would come up and um
top cello covers of popular songs so i
don't know if you're doing covers um but
it looks like here i'm getting just a
lot of different cello like learn
uh learn
to play the cello
for beginners online i i mean you
already have courses on this so i would
maybe make one of this and get yourself
in this ranking area as well to be
driving traffic to your online courses
and that was our take on what you should
be doing as a cello player okay this
question comes from i eat bubbles
not sure what your channel's about i
don't know if your channel is actually
about eating bubbles i'm not clicked on
it yet but i have a podcast for my
channel
a good thing
is having a podcast for my channel a
good thing what do you think about this
rob
good question and
my
thoughts and opinions are starting to
percolate a little bit as youtube is
actively encouraging people to now
put their podcasts on
the youtube platform
traditionally i've always thought
that
if i was um i listened to podcasts i
very rarely watched them and so to turn
a
what i think is an audio format into
something visually interesting you're
gonna have to put a lot of effort into
setting up you know like a studio
running it through stream yards
there's a lot more
overhead to do that
but
i think youtube are definitely working
on ways to make podcasts more integrated
into
channels whether that means there's
going to be a dedicated podcast shelf
you know live as a short shelf that
would make the most sense to me i'm not
entirely sure but i think creator
insider recently did a video about um
podcasts and you you know when you're um
you can see the chips or the bubbles um
at the top of the screen and you can
search through different topics podcast
is becoming one of them so from a
youtube perspective they are well aware
of podcasts and they are i think
at the moment just slightly nudging
people to start experimenting with
podcasts but as i say you've also got to
think about the visual element we
ordered the channel yesterday that just
started their podcast channel and every
single thumbnail was exactly the same
and every single title started with
episode x
and then maybe what it was about and
then the
when we were watching the podcast
there was no b-roll there was no
switching of clips it was you know
visually a little boring to watch and so
if you are going to do podcasts you
really have to appreciate that you're on
a visual medium as well but those are
kind of like my initial first
impressions like we haven't tried to
introduce podcasts onto the vid iq um
channel yet but we are live streaming on
a podcast channel right now ever so
lovely off to hear your thoughts
yeah we uh we went back and forth on if
we were gonna put our podcast that's the
channel we're on right now the think
media podcast channel um if we were
gonna put that actually on our think
media channel and for us you know we
really wanted to know what was the value
proposition that we that our channel was
like why do people subscribe to the
think media channel and we wanted to go
deeper in the conversations as creators
we wanted to go deeper in different
interviews that maybe step outside of
just youtube in general meaning like
monetizing your channel doing live
events um writing books you know
different ways that you could be
actually in the creator economy and we
knew that that wasn't quite the value
proposition of the think media channel
itself where we do a lot of tech gear
reviews we do a lot of youtube specific
tips and we wanted to have a space where
we could step outside of that and have
longer form conversations around those
and so we decided to do it on a separate
channel now i do not recommend that
people run two channels at one time we
actually didn't even start our podcast
we waited two years to start it because
we wanted to have the right team in
place because when you are already a
content creator on one channel and now
you're doubling the amount of work that
you have to do that's not a wise idea so
we wanted to make sure that there was
team around us so i have an editor for
the podcasting show i have a producer
that's helping me with the show
or with the podcast so it's not just me
and sean making that possible um i would
say too i do agree with you rob that uh
youtube is leaning more into this
because of successfully proven podcasts
like the joe rogan podcast valuetainment
podcast you know all these podcasts that
are really popping up in more video form
but you're right there's an initial
investment into it and the other part of
it too is um
like you said
if someone is used to just listening
then getting them to be a viewer isn't
what you're trying to do you're actually
trying to reach two different audiences
so now you're even splitting your time
even more because an audio experience is
different than a video experience and so
i would say that it is a great way to
build an audience it's more of a slow
way slower way there's other ways to
grow faster on youtubes i.e youtube
shorts i.e influence surfing or trend
surfing or making uh videos that that
have the potential of going viral
podcasts you are asking someone to
invest a lot of time with you and if
you're not very large yet that might not
be the best way to get started so that
would be some of my advice uh on
podcasting specifically rob what channel
do you have up next
next we have up weird data and i'm not
gonna lie
uh i have a bit of a soft spot for
channels that just display
data in a visually satisfying way
that's the good part of this and i can
see that
although they've hidden their subscriber
count i'm guessing they've got i'm gonna
guess in the region of between a
thousand subscribers plus because some
of their videos get hundreds of views
some of their videos get tens of
thousands of views
what i'm going to say about this channel
though is that
when you tend to have these
really interesting channels which do
something new and it's never been seen
before the problem is it gets seen
very often
very quickly
and i've seen channels like this
for years with the i'll play one but
i'll mute it to make sure we don't get
any copyright music claims but
i've been seeing these types of channels
for years
and so my concern is how is this channel
any different from the thousands of data
analysis channels that i've already seen
and that's where you what tends to
happen again in these areas is that you
get one or two channels that completely
dominate this space and it's very
difficult for anybody else to um
interfere but again yeah it's really
visually satisfying these 3d blocks
rotating and rising and
this always keeps you on the edge of oh
what's next so it's discord all right
another second later instagram
misspelled unfortunately but i'm getting
that instant gratification every couple
of seconds of what's coming next
and so that will help with audience
retention i guess how you may be able to
tackle this is that you become a data
analyst for a particular topic
maybe it's sports teams maybe it's food
maybe it's military maybe it's global
demographics if i sort by most popular
is there any particular thing that's
better than anything else
i guess at the moment we've got like a
needle in a haystack result in terms of
we've got geology we've got flags we've
got cartoon characters we've got soft
drinks we've got legendary heroes
would it be better to maybe niche down
into one of these areas and be the
master
of that particular area something
perhaps worth experiencing with in the
next five videos and i do want to stress
as well heather this is kind of my
personal opinion in terms of these types
of channels
and i think once
one channel does this successfully
tons of other channels try to replicate
it and it becomes
an oversaturated market very quickly i
mean
a year or two ago it was you know it was
those like bar graphs that were
competing with each other and then they
would go up and down i think it was
flourish the data website where you
could do that and i made a couple
but i knew very quickly that i was going
to be overtaken by channels that were
dedicated to making that type of content
and we had to stop doing it because it
just wasn't really appealing to our
audience um but yeah
this channel will suffer from spiky
views i think depending on the topic
that they're covering
well thanks for that one rob and i do i
also like these kind too i know my kids
and i especially um since we homeschool
we actually love these types of channels
for specific information specific data
but you're right i go to like one
channel for one type of topic not
necessarily just an overview of
different topics so i love that uh
review this one is true malme i hope i'm
saying that your name correctly and uh
she's been on youtube for a year now
been creating content for a year at 1
000 subscribers congratulations on
hitting the 1000 subscriber mark
and i have a little bit of feedback for
you when i went to your about page at
first i saw your channel and um number
one uh i want you to check out the
different thumbnail videos that we have
here on think media maybe someone in the
comments could recommend one of those
videos by posting that inside of there
for me but we have several different
videos around actual thumbnail design
because i want to help you
get better at your thumbnails when i
look at things like thanks for watching
please kindly subscribe i i'm not
actually that to me is such an ask
versus giving real uh solid um a value
in what you're actually doing on your
channel so i went over and i looked at
your about page so that i could get more
information about what you're doing and
here is
one of the main new creator mistakes
that people make i love that you're
creating content on a regular basis i
love that you've been creating content
for a year now but we have got to decide
what this channel is about let me read
this paragraph rob okay
this channel is for motivation advice
and encouragement i also share my
experience and life stories of how i
traveled from lebanon to europe marriage
advice parenthood advice and i also
share videos of english countryside and
cities i also vlog and do reaction
videos
and that is seven channels in one
channel
so i'm going to challenge you to pick
one or two you could do marriage and
parenting advice you could do all about
traveling from lebanon to europe and all
about the english countryside you could
even include your experience and your
life stories in those but i'm going to
encourage you to actually pick one
because when i come down here and i look
at the videos that you're creating i
think you have a shot at being a very
highly um
highly viewed uh youtuber because of i
was watching some of your videos about
the experiences that you've had however
this is not feeding enough information
to youtube or to the audience about what
you are doing so i want you to go deeper
i'm seeing like silent videos so these
are videos that you're making that's it
that's its own channel that's its own
style of channel um i see live streams
where you're talking about your
infertility that could be its own
channel or it could just be um uh one in
the terms of parenting and motherhood uh
in marriage so i want you to go deeper
on figuring out what your channel is all
about now here's one thing that i do
love you've actually got a good base of
an audience that's watching what you're
doing i'm seeing your videos between
a hundred and three hundred but there
hasn't quite been
the massive breakout videos yet you're
getting 2 000 here but again this is
about a specific place this is about a
specific place this is about a specific
place so if i were to look at the clues
of what's working on your channel so far
i would say this is working on your
channel so i want you to study your top
10 videos and take notes of what's
working was it your intro was it the
title was it the thumbnail what was
consistent in those top 10 videos so
that you can start making more of those
videos i want to encourage you to keep
going because i see that you're even
you're live streaming you've got some
live streams scheduled and coming up so
congratulations on getting content out
there but we need to rein it in reign it
in a little bit and really decide on
what your channel is about all right rob
what is your last review for today i did
just have one quick question uh if you
could watch the channel um what's your
opinion
on
smaller creators premiering content
because i've noticed these channels
they're premiering something in what is
three days time
yeah yeah i actually i think that um
i think that for creators to stay
consistent they should know that they're
doing it but i don't actually feel like
premieres as a small channel
is a tactic that is something that you
would need to do i think just go live if
you're gonna go live um premieres are
really great if you have built that
audience because what you do in a
premiere is you get a lot of people to
watch at that one time and youtube is
triggered and they go whoa there's a lot
of people here right now let's get this
out to more people and it's a way for
you to have a conversation during the
premiere so we will premiere um week
premiere what we call our marathon
videos on think media those are our
videos that are longer than about 45
minutes and it's like a movie premiere
basically we show up with our popcorn
and we talk in the chat and we we make
it an event but we actually don't
overuse that we really make it an event
to be a part of and i see a lot of small
creators that will just make this like
anytime they go live they do a premiere
so not necessary to do
yeah i would tend to agree
i still think of youtube as being
something where everything is
immediately accessible
so the moment i see that something is
premiering in like a few days time and
it's a thumbnail that's on my browse
page it's like really frustrating
because you're showing me something that
i can't watch
why are you doing that to me youtube but
that's just a personal opinion but
i also share your thoughts in that if
you haven't built up a community and you
aren't able to build up anticipation
with a large audience that's going to
flood that premiere and give you a
huge dollop of watch time when the video
first goes out it's probably just to
publish it when you're ready to publish
it
yes and thank you so much for being here
for the live stream rob's got one more
uh for us
who's the lucky last one today rob buff
bass or buff bass fishing adventures
with the kind of indiana jones font
there kind of like i love it
what i want to say about this channel is
that
for its size and for the number of
videos that they've made in one month
i'm gonna
make an assumption
that this might not be the channels for
that might not be the creator's first
channel because there are so many
fundamentals that are on point here
like
this channel banner immediately tells
you that it's a fishing channel like and
you know if we if we went back to the
channel that we just audited uh the
heather you would probably look at that
channel for like 20 seconds and you
wouldn't be entirely sure if you're in
the right place with that that creators
content but here they're about fishing
they're about the big catch brilliant
the thumbnails i think are phenomenal
because whenever we order fishing
channels the one thing we always ask is
what is the hero of the thumbnail and
it's usually the catch the fish that you
have and you can see that this crater is
trying to show the scale of a catch
whenever they can which is fantastic
and even when they're reviewing a
product which looks like it is here
they're making sure that they have the
arrow pointing to it and so again it's
telling my eyes where to go on the
thumbnail and also
many fishing channels do this thing
where they contrast blues and greens
because that's kind of a landscape
they're usually in and they're doing
that very effectively so all i have here
is nothing but praise they're
experimenting with shorts the shorts are
getting fantastic views um it's one of
these where maybe just want to quickly
watch one of the shots i'll make sure to
mute it
just in case there's any music and i'm
trying to see how quickly the shot is oh
there's got the catch we're straight in
there no missing about now he's
wrestling about with a fish showing a
bit of slow motion there you know
there's no wasted effort in this shot
this is visually satisfied there you are
and i've got the catch there that took
what 15 seconds i guess what i wouldn't
do is fade to black i would just loop it
next i would loop it immediately around
because i knew the shot had ended then
and i would swipe onto the next one but
yeah for a channel that's what have it a
month in they've made like 30 videos
they've already got past uh 100
subscribers so they've got their custom
url they've already got shorts that are
getting thousands of views yeah it's all
it's all success big thumbs up this is a
template channel that i think any
creator could look at
for
things in terms of thumbnails in terms
of channel focus terms of consistency
and the video quality looks very good as
well i'm sorry um
both bass fishing adventures if i
haven't really given you too much advice
but it's just carry on what you're doing
and i would estimate within three to six
months you'll probably monetize this
channel
yeah that's exactly what i see too and
rob can you um can you start a channel
where you're reacting because your voice
over his fishing experience right there
like elevated the whole thing so uh that
was that was pretty awesome and you're
right this is a great channel um to end
on to show the great things that you can
do on youtube how you can take a hobby
and turn it into a career and i am so
excited to see what happens with this
channel if you just stay consistent if
you just keep making great videos great
thumbnails um build out your channel a
little bit more uh with um you know more
just consistent content and i think
you're gonna see a lot of success
happening because this is a huge
huge space you know part of the thing
that we talk about too rob when it comes
to picking what channel what your
channel should even be about
is you want to make sure that you're
passionate about it i'm sure he's
passionate about bass fishing right that
he's actually here creating a channel
about this but also are you proficient
in it he's catching fish yes he's
proficient in catching fish but is it a
profitable niche as well and when you
think about the uh stores dedicated to
just fishing when you think about the
magazines just to fishing when you think
about on the online stores that are just
for fishing you know that there is a
market that you can jump into when it
comes to that so i think that was a
great channel to end with we want to
remind you that if you have not already
gotten your vid iq you can go to
vidiq.com
think to get your first 30 days of vidiq
for free rob thank you so much for being
my lovely co-host today on the channel
we're going to be over on the vid iq
channel i think next week because you
guys do channel reviews over there live
once a week once every two week what's
your schedule right now
so we do channel audits every tuesday at
the same time as when we went live here
11 a.m pst and we're also continuing to
experiment with video audits whereby we
play a video and you know how was
reacting to that shot just saying we
talk about like if the intro was gonna
keep me hooked like how is the
production quality are they using end
screens and those are on wednesdays
so whichever one you're invited to
heather we're looking forward to it i'm
excited for that well thank you so much
rob and if you would like to check out
our podcast here you can click or tap on
the next video that shows up on the
screen if you want to see another
channel review from heather and rob you
can click or tap the screen right now
and we'll catch it in the next show are
you ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com